in march of 2020 as the pandemic took
hold
unemployment in the u.s began to spike
the federal government passed a 2.2
trillion dollar stimulus bill
money for the unemployed loans for
businesses and
twelve hundred dollar stimulus checks
sent to millions of americans
in december the government sent out even
more checks
and then in march 2021 even more
all this government spending made this
guy very concerned
seems to me we're taking very
substantial risks what was
kindling is now igniting larry summers
he used to be bill clinton's treasury
secretary and barack obama's top
economic advisor
and he thought the checks were a mistake
we're gonna
set ourselves up for inflation you know
inflation when prices
increase and money is worth less and
less like the u.s had in the 70s
or in the extreme in places like
venezuela
where money is so worthless it's used to
make purses
so are these checks actually something
to worry about
and could they lead to this first we
have to talk about how inflation works
think of the economy as a fish tank when
one fish spends their money like out at
a fish concert
that keeps other fish like the venue
workers employed
so they can go spend their money on
things too like
their mortgage or a car because
fish need cars stick with me it's a
cycle
employed fish spend money which keeps
other fish employed
some of that money also goes into their
savings to spend later
and think of all the water in the tank
as all the money being spent
out in the economy in an ideal economy
fish unemployment is low and there's
lots of money being spent
and so there's a comfortable amount of
water in the tank
but in a recession lots of fish lose
their jobs
and stop spending money and other fish
get scared that they might be next
so they stop spending and start saving
and with less money being spent in the
economy the water level
falls
when that happens the government can
pump more money or water
into the economy it can be through
things like investments in
infrastructure
or unemployment benefits but in the last
20 years
one policy that's been used more and
more frequently
is stimulus checks giving people cash
directly to
go and spend checks are definitely
something that
many economists think are useful because
it bypasses the traditional channels
the first stimulus check as we know it
came in 2001. it was really more like an
early tax refund
it gave adults who had paid at least six
thousand dollars in income taxes
a three hundred dollar check studies
found that it went swimmingly
people did spend the money and the
checks were credited with helping to end
the 2001 recession
this approach was so popular that in the
next recession in 2008
the government did it again this time
they sent out twice as much money in tax
rebates
it was phased out for higher income
americans but expanded in other ways
most families got a bit extra for each
child people with less income
got a check too though smaller it was
just a part of a larger stimulus package
but
studies found that it worked again this
time even more people
quickly spent their checks they give
money to people fast
and it helps the economy which then in
turn helps more families
but here's the problem normally
businesses raise their prices
a little bit each year but it's not very
noticeable since
people usually make a little bit more
each year
this is inflation prices going up
and we can measure it as the water level
in the tank higher prices mean more
money being spent
so a higher water level but if suddenly
these fish have
way more money to spend businesses can
raise their prices
a lot drastically higher prices mean too
much water in the tank and it could
overflow
this is the bad inflation
but economists actually want a little
inflation each year
spending is a sign of a growing economy
it's not a bad thing
in fact if prices aren't rising it tells
you that
something is really wrong in the economy
this is what inflation has looked like
in the u.s the last 40 years
zero means prices haven't changed from
the year before
four percent means things cost four
percent more than last year
and here in these gray bars are when the
economy was in a recession
notice anything a recession almost
always comes with a substantial dip in
inflation
when people lose their jobs or are
afraid they're next
they don't spend like usual businesses
can't raise their prices like they
usually would
when this line falls below zero meaning
things actually cost
less than they did a year ago that's bad
falling prices is a sign of an economy
in crisis and frankly an economy in a
downward spiral
and for the last 10 years the u.s has
aimed for 2 percent inflation
and you can say well why two percent and
their argument is we want a little bit
of a buffer
but the u.s leading up to the pandemic
didn't have much of that buffer
we weren't consistently hitting that two
percent
and then our fish tank was under attack
we lost a lot of that water very
suddenly we saw the federal government
slap some tape on the fishbowl throw
some more water in
one thing they did that was really
popular was to send checks to people
and this time stimulus checks were sent
out to even more people than the ones in
2001 and 2008
basically anyone with a social security
number plus
extra for children and it worked then
too
you can see here in the chart of
americans bank accounts people's
balances went up with the stimulus
checks
and down as they spent them it put more
water into the tank
but then the government sent out more
and even more
this is what worried some economists if
the government pours in
all this water and then people start
going out and spending again
including what they've saved that's a
lot of water
wouldn't it make the tank overflow
most economists say probably not
it's really important to remember that
we lost
a lot of water the risk right now
is doing too little it would have to be
a sudden
explosion of spending
most economists including the ones
trying to steer the us economy
agree not to worry we could see a little
inflation as the economy reopens but
not at overflow levels there is debate
around stimulus checks but it's in the
details
who should get them and how much should
they be many economists even want them
to go out automatically
when the economy shows signs of a
recession starting having a
rule in place that automatically adjusts
the water level
without political headaches of getting
it passed through congress
when the unemployment rate rises just a
little bit we're in a recession
bad news bad stuff is coming send the
checks
but as for inflation economists today
want a little
and aren't really concerned about
overflowing the tank sorry larry
doing too little right now listening to
the people who are
so afraid of the fish tank overflowing
i think that would be a big mistake
[Music]
you